diese sind die schreie der hungernden
und durch die bewohner der erreichen
finanzmetropole shanghai am 10 april
2022 sie dürfen ihre wohnungen nicht
verlassen da die größenwahnsinnig und
kontrollsysteme regierungschefin pings
einen haken lockdown über ihre und
weitere 23 städte mit über
193 millionen einwohnern verhängt hat
ohne die versorgung mit nahrung und
trinkwasser sicher zu stellen alle nicht
verketten brechen gerade zusammen und
das leitungswasser in china ist sowieso
ungenießbar das politische und
gesellschaftliche system der supermacht
steht an einem wendepunkt und wie manche
meinen gar vor dem kollaps was das alles
mit den olympischen spielen in peking zu
tun hat die vor knapp zwei monaten zu
ende gegangen sind verraten wir euch den
diesem video
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn man versucht eine olympiade in
einem land auszurichten dass sich
verbissen und mit karten lockt bei uns
selbst gegen die endemische ausbreitung
der omicron variante des corona virus
werden kann dabei nicht viel mehr
herauskommen als etwas so was wie das
ende von game of thrones irgendwie passt
das ganze nicht es sollte eine großes
fest des sports werden und dann sind
alle tribünen leer so war es letzten
sommer in tokio gewesen und so lief es
auch bei den olympischen winterspielen
in china
[Musik]
durch die aktuellsten jedoch nicht nur
die zuschauer vor ort sondern auch
weltweit vor den fernsehern und handys
ok wintersport weckte globales war immer
schon etwas weniger leidenschaft aber
ein solches maß an desinteresse wie in
diesem jahr hatte man noch nicht erlebt
stellten die spiele vor vier jahren in
südkorea bereits einen absoluten
tiefpunkt da haben sich die
einschaltquoten
2020 nochmals halbiert falls sich also
noch etwas außer der moral der
russischen armee im freien fall befindet
dann ist es ganz sicher olympia und ben
gegen 2022 mal in die schlagzeilen
geriet dann nicht wegen des
medaillenkampf sondern wegen eines ganz
anderen rekordes eines rekords der
dreistigkeit wenn es darum ging den
sport für politische zwecke zu
missbrauchen aufgrund des krieges in der
ukraine mussten wir dieses video nach
hinten schieben wollten es euch aber auf
gar keinen fall vorenthalten denn diese
clown fiesta muss man einfach gesehen
haben aber eins nach dem anderen im
grunde handelt es sich um einen
verwaisten versuch des regimes campings
den erfolg der spiele von 2008 zu
wiederholen und für sich zu
instrumentalisieren
tatsächlich hat die chinesische
propaganda nicht aufgehört die tatsache
zu betonen dass peking die erste stadt
ist welche sowohl die olympischen sommer
als auch die winterspiele ausgerichtet
hat und in gewisser weise war das
durchaus logisch wir alle erinnern uns
allen peking 2008 als im moment in dem
der asiatischen riesen erwarte und sich
der welt als große wirtschaftliche
supermacht präsentierte
[Musik]
das monumentale an ein fantastisches
vogelnest erinnernde nationalstadion
wurde zu einer ikone des neuen modernen
china ein riesenerfolg in sachen
nationales image marketing der auch mit
einem sportlichen erfolg für die
gastgeber nation einhergehen china
gewann er goldmedaillen als je zuvor und
führte den medaillenspiegel zum ersten
mal in der geschichte an aber mein leben
das war politik zuschauer seit 2008
hätten sich die dinge nicht stärker
verändert haben können die regierung
beiden dort angesichts des völkermords
und verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
engine sowie anderer
menschenrechtsverletzungen in der
volksrepublik china keine diplomatische
oder offizielle vertretung zu den
olympischen und paralympischen
winterspielen 2022 in peking entsenden
denn zac die pressesprecherin des weißen
hauses von der us-regierung
angekündigten boykott wurde von
australien kanada und den vereinigten
königreich und neuseeland unterstützt
auch japan deutschland dänemark und die
niederlande schlossen sich dem boykott
an es sollte jedoch klar gestellt werden
dass dieser boykott nur diplomatischen
charakter hatte und in keinem fall zum
rückzug von athleten geführt hat okay
immerhin haben im letzten jahr viel
länder ihre stimme erhoben sie prangern
die menschenrechtsverletzungen an die
china an den uiguren begeht die
unterdrückung der freiheit in hongkong
und das mobbing gegenteil war
[Musik]
wohlgemerkt damals ging es noch nicht
darum dass sie den überfall seines busen
falls putin auf die ukraine decken wird
obwohl es als gesichert gelten kann dass
er seine pläne zu diesem zeitpunkt schon
kannte und putin aus rücksicht auf ski
mit dem krieg auf das ende der
olympischen spiele gewartet hat und zwar
so wie schon 2008 vor dem georgienkrieg
man will seinem einzigen großen kumpel
ja nicht die party vermasseln nun ja
eine partie ist es auch so nicht
geworden und die frage lautet daher wie
wollte das kommunistische regime von
sheshan bringt die spiele für sich
nutzen wie wollte der westen dies
verhindern und was noch wichtiger durch
den russischen kanonendonner jedoch
untergegangen ist was ist eigentlich aus
der ganzen geschichte geworden was haben
die spiel über das china von heute und
sein regime enthüllt haben wir wasser
passt welche geopolitischen auswirkungen
wird das alles auf uns haben heute
werden wir all diese fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar wie so oft zunächst
mit hilfe eines kurzen blick in die
geschichte
[Musik]
eine rein symbolische maßnahme
boykotte großer sportereignisse sind wie
billige sexuelle anspielungen in einem
red sie gehören einfach dazu
das ziel ist in der regel das balco
titel land unter druck zu setzen damit
es irgendwas macht unter lässt oder sich
irgendwie ändert wie so eine art
emotionaler erpressung durch
liebesentzug tja wer war nicht schon mal
in so eine toxischen beziehung und die
er sicher daraus gelernt habe ist ein
solches verhalten meist wenig
zielführend und auch nicht konstruktiv
aber die emotionalen wunden und in
diesem fall die schlagzeilen bleiben
wenn orban ball so nahe oder maduro
solches verhalten an den tag legen sagen
natürlich alle gleich dass es sich um
nichts als populistische geste handelt
und in der tat es gibt nichts in
konsequenteres kontraproduktives und um
dieses abgedroschen wort auch zu nutzen
populistisches als einen boykott
anzudrohen und ihnen dann nicht
durchzuführen ohne dass sich in der
zwischenzeit irgendetwas geändert hätte
tja und so war es auch bei den
olympischen spielen damals 1936 in
berlin viele länder drohten damit nicht
teilzunehmen um gegen das nazi regime zu
protestieren
am ende nahmen 49 länder teilt so viele
wie nie zuvor zum glück verschafften
jesse owens der freien welt etwas
genugtuung
[Musik]
tja dann kam der kalte krieg und die
mutter aller boykotte 2080 verzichteten
die usa und 60 andere länder auf die
olympischen spiele in moskau dies war
ein protest gegen die sowjetische
invasion in afghanistan
vier jahre später war die sowjetunion an
der reihe dies zusammen mit anderen
ostblockländern die spiele 1984 in los
angeles kolportierte nun ja wie effektiv
all diese orte waren wissen wir nur zu
gut aus der geschichte aber wartet mal
denn es gab einen boykott der eine
gewisse wirkung hatte aus protest gegen
die apartheid wurde südafrika zwischen
1964 und sich die teilnahme an großen
sportereignissen untersagt dabei handelt
es sich wohl um den erfolgreichsten
boykott der sportgeschichte vielleicht
der einzige der tatsächlich eine
politische wirkung hatte das problem ist
dass sich diese art von walcott gingen
an giganten china einfach nicht
wiederholen konnte wir reden hier über
das bevölkerungsreichste land der welt
und das bedeutet dass es sich um einen
der wichtigsten märkte für das
internationale olympische komitee
handelt es standen einfach zu viele
interessen auf dem spiel auch für die
amerikaner denn abgesehen von den
athleten - und 80 in moskau nicht
antreten konnten war der größte
verlierer des damaligen wolters der
fernsehsender nbc der die rechte für die
übertragung der spiele in den
vereinigten staaten erworben hatte und
danach 22 millionen us dollar miese
machte
[Musik]
es war daher undenkbar dass der boykott
gegen spiele in peking über die
diplomatie hinaus geht die regierung von
shipping hat versucht die sache noch
weiter herunter zu spielen indem sie
versicherte dass us-vertreter sich doch
gar nicht weigern könnten so einer party
zu gehen der sieht gar nicht eingeladen
worden und dann wäre da noch schau die
an ein sprecher des chinesischen
außenministeriums und ausgesprochener
hardliner der kp wer glaubt dass das
beste was china tun kann um die
geschehnisse entschieden junk zu
rechtfertigen darin besteht in die
offensive zu gehen die usa wurden auf
der ausplünderung des heimatlandes der
indianer und auf verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit aufgebaut mit welchem
recht verlangten sie die ethnische
politik anderer länder durch lügen und
desinformation welche versteckten
absichten stecken hinter all ihren
gerüchten und verleumdungen wie man nur
unschwer erkennen kann die dies ein ganz
kleines bisschen über den typischen
austausch diplomatische erklärungen
zwischen regierungen zweier
rivalisierender länder hinaus aber wir
sollten uns nichts vormachen der boykott
blieb eine mehr oder weniger symbolische
maßnahme welche an den zuständen
innerhalb chinas rein gar nichts ändern
konnte der punkt ist jedoch dass er
nicht nur aus diesem grund überflüssig
war nein er war gar nicht notwendig den
schnitzelbängg hast dich sowieso selbst
ein bein gestellt und ihr werdet euch
vielleicht fragen wie wir das meinen und
warum wird dieses thema überhaupt ein
ganzes video fußball politik widmen ich
weine gibt es nicht bedeutenderes team
nun wir gleich sehen werden
synchronisiert gerade olympia 2022 auf
außerordentlich köstlich und treffende
weise jene plumpe inkompetenz und
verwirrung und jene gigantischen
probleme in welche sich die globale
supermacht china hinein manövriert hat
[Musik]
ein haufen yuan und ein wenig schnee
im juli 2015 peking als austragungsort
der winterspiele 2022 ausgewählt damals
war das tram nur bei den simpsons
präsident der vereinigten staaten oder
westen zeigte noch nichts so viel
misstrauen gegenüber china heute hat
sich die situation jedoch dramatisch
verändert china davor der ganzen welt
immer misstrauischer folgt und das gilt
auch für die olympische spiele um euch
eine vorstellung zu geben oslo hat seine
bewerbung für diese spiele zurückgezogen
nachdem es zeuge der kostenexplosion der
olympische spiele im russischen sotchi
2014 geworden war und der andere
konkurrent pekings war nur schultern für
diejenigen die es nicht wissen nur
schultern ist die hauptstadt kasachstans
und welche anforderungen stellt das
internationale olympische komitee an
eine stadt welche die olympischen
winterspiele ausrichten darf
[Musik]
nun einige von euch werden denken dass
das wichtigste ist dass die
gastgeberstadt schnee hat oder so ganz
und gar nicht fast sein gesamtes schnee
bei den olympischen winterspielen in
peking wird künstlich seien genau die
olympischen winterspiele fanden an einem
ort statt in dem es selten schneit es in
london das wetter in peking ist trocken
fast wüsten artig also mussten sie ein
wassertransport system bauen das mehr
als 223 millionen liter wasser benötigt
so viel braucht man um all die
notwendigen schneemaschinen zu versorgen
wir sprechen von hunderten von
schneekanonen von der energiebilanz des
ganzen spektakels mal ganz zu schweigen
es scheint echt nur eine frage der zeit
zu sein bis die winterspiele nach dubai
vergeben werden denn was war der grund
für diesen monumentalen unsinn nur den
wesentlichen liegt ist an zwei
schlüsselfaktoren der erste ist
propaganda
[Musik]
welcher größenwahnsinnige diktator würde
sich denn nicht gerne damit brüsten dass
seine hauptstadt die erste stadt war in
der sowohl die olympischen sommer als
auch die winterspiele ausgerichtet
wurden wäre doch gelacht und damit das
ganze irgendwie geht wirkt und auch zum
aktuellen fünfjahresplan passt konnte
man den ganzen doch einen grünen
anstrich verleihen oder warum sollte man
das ganze nicht als umweltfreundliches
recycling spiel verkaufen man braucht
dazu hier nur ein paar sportstätten von
2008 zu renovieren so wurde aus dem
water cube in dem schäfer erschütterung
stattfanden jetzt der ice cube für
curling veranstaltungen das handball und
gymnastik stadion wurde zur heimat des
eishockeys und im vogelnest stadion
fanden die da die eröffnungs und
abschlussfeier lichkeiten statt dumm nur
dass die olympischen aussagen zur otto
schack und jan klinger sage und schreibe
100 beziehungsweise 200 kilometer von
peking entfernt sind und so eine
pendelei ist nicht nur nervig sagt passt
auch nicht ganz zum grünen image welches
die partei neuerdings tragen möchte aber
wir sind doch in china da können wir
ganz einfach mal eine brandneue
hochgeschwindigkeitsbahn in die
skigebiete bauen kostet doch nur
schlappe neun milliarden dollar ein
pappenstiel wen interessiert es denn
dass die nach lybien niemand mehr nutzen
wird das skifahren in china nicht gerade
einen breiten sport darstellt
schließlich gelöst erschien die
entwicklung von skigebieten in der nähe
von peking fördern um damit seine
wohlhabende mittelschicht zu bedienen
[Musik]
denn in china ist skifahren ein synonym
für sozialen status da muss der
klassenkampf markt kurz pause machen
oder einen seiner vielen pausen im
pseudo kommunistischen china aber alles
egal denn wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt
ging ist in peking nur darum dass dieses
spiel ein meisterwerk der propaganda
werden deshalb haben sie alles bis ins
kleinste detail durchorganisiert
china warnt ausländische olympioniken
davor sich bei den winterspielen über
politik zu äußern und die tatsache dass
es keine öffentlichkeit gab machte es
für das kommunistische regime viel
einfacher jede art von protest zu
kontrollieren es war schon verdammt
auffällig dass die regierung wickelt
hartnäckig daran festhielt die teilnahme
von zuschauern einen spielen aus corona
gründen zu verbieten wäre den westen die
zuschauer längst zu ihrem
sportveranstaltungen zurückgekehrt sind
aber sowohl die zero kowitz sackgasse in
die idee sein land hinein manövriert hat
als auf der mega fell seines verbündeten
putin in der ukraine sind nur symptome
eines viel größeren übergeordneten
problems aus dem ski so schnell nicht
wieder heraus kommt also aufgepasst denn
jetzt führen wir die fäden zusammen
zwischen pings gruselige clown fiesta
das jahr 2022 sollte für shopping ein
wichtiges jahr werden eine glorreiches
jahr denn theoretisch hätte es das ja
seines abschied sein soll so war es bei
johnson und auch bei hu jintao gewesen
die nach zehn jahren an der macht ihr
amt aufgaben aber liebe visa politik
setzt dieses mal wird es anders sein
alles deutet darauf hin dass der
parteitag der kommunistischen partei im
nächsten herbst skijumping erneut zum
präsidenten chinas erwandert und zwar
bis nun ja ist dieser herr des regierens
irgendwann selbst müde werden wird im
reinsten stil nun ja da er sich trotzdem
auch an seinen direkten vorgänger messen
lassen muss wollte er nach zehn jahren
wenigstens eine zwischenbilanz ziehen
eine auf biegen und brechen positive aus
diesem grund mussten die olympische
spiele perfekt werden skijumping wollte
bei der organisation nichts dem zufall
überlassen er wollte dass das land noch
einmal die gleiche anerkennung erhält
wie bei den spielen 2008 in peking daher
hat china heute noch mehr als damals
beide organisationen der olympischen
spiele keine kosten und mühen gescheut
14 jahren überrascht mich lesen die welt
auf positive weise und boten jedem der
volt einen riesigen markt der sich immer
mehr öffnete und hoffnung gab auf eine
zukunft des friedens und der
zusammenarbeit doch die globale
landschaft hat sich seither stark
verändert so beginn des jahrhunderts
glaubte man im westen dass der dialog
mit china zu einer größeren
liberalisierung und öffnung des
kommunistischen regimes führen würde das
motto hieß wandel durch handel nun ja
diese hoffnung hat shipping und seine
clique den garaus gemacht sie 2012 an
die macht kam hat sich der wind in china
gedreht oder das reich der mitte ist
wieder zu einem zunehmend autoritären
staat geworden im gegensatz zum
diskreten profil eines hu jintao jinping
eine aggressive außenpolitik losgetreten
und natürlich war der konflikt mit dem
westen unausweichlich vor allem seit
trump im weißen haus platz nahmen skis
hauptproblem ist also nicht das olympia
2022 in peking ein wirtschaftliches
desaster darstellt denn ein paar jahren
mehr oder weniger sind eindeutig die
geringste seiner sorgen die sei ein
hauptproblem ist dass das für die katz
war dass die spiele auch auf der
propaganda eben ein vollständiger
misserfolg waren und sie ein weiteres
mal sein zweifelhaftes geschickte diesen
hat wenn es darum geht eine große
gelegenheit ordentlich zu vermasseln das
versagen wird immer klarer und der
großteil der welt sieht china bereits
mit ganz anderen augen
zuerst war der dollar stores
handelskrieg dann die vereinnahmung
hongkongs mit der brutalen unterdrückung
der versprochenen souveränitätsrechte
und dann kam das corona virus dabei geht
es nicht nur um seinen ursprung und den
verdacht dass höchstwahrscheinlich die
unverantwortlichen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen im johanna wären
labor in kombination mit dem dorfbrunnen
verantwortlichen faktisch jungs
versuchen des regimes der welt eine
pandemie und eine gigantische rezession
beschert haben es geht auch darum dass
china die untersuchungen über die
herkunft 19 behindert hat wo es nur ging
inklusive scharfe angriffe gegen jedes
land das mehr transparenz forderte in
erster linie australien eines loyalen
handelspartner denn nun zum erzfeind
geworden ist hinzu kommen die andauern
und wahrlich pubertären provokationen
gegenüber teil waren die nur davon
zeugen wie viel angst und nervosität im
pekinger regime davor herrscht seine
untertanen könnten sich die dortige
freiheit doch eines tages zum vorbild
nehmen übrigens handelt es sich um eine
sehr starke analogie zur angst putins
vor einer freien und erfolgreichen
ukraine welche den russen zeigen würde
in welchem system sie selbst leben
müssen vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch
daran wie china im jahr 2020 die welt
mit seiner masken diplomatie verführen
wollte der erfolg war damals eher
zweifelhaft im jahr 2021 sollte china
diese operation wiederholen diesmal mit
impfstoff diplomatie und in diesem fall
war der misserfolg durchschlagend
der anstieg von kogit 0 sind infektionen
in einigen ländern die chinesische
impfstoffe verwendet haben lässt zweifel
an deren wirksamkeit aufkommen die miese
qualität der chinesischen impfstoffe und
die entlarvung des totalen scheiterns
der korona london politik pekings haben
dem image chinas in vielen ländern
erheblich geschadet diejenigen die
gehofft hatten china würde seine 0 kurve
ideologie lokal mussten im april 2022
eine herbe enttäuschung erleben der die
ganze welt kapiert hat dass das virus
nun in dem spröden ist und es keinen
sinn macht sich mit aller gewalt gegen
die natur zu stemmen ohne die oberste
politische führung den totalen locker
und seiner 25 millionen metropole
shanghai an das zentrum der chinesischen
finanzwirtschaft war aus guten grund
bisher eher locker mit nicht
medizinischen maßnahmen umgegangen aber
ausgerechnet jetzt wenn die pandemie
vorbei ist greift das regime hat
durchaus signalisiert auch deutlich dass
ein ende der repressionen nicht in sicht
sei der scheinbar direkt von shipping
vorgegebene und jegliche
wissenschaftlichen faxen ignorierende
noch schärfere 0-coup kurs offenbart
angesichts der charakteristika der
omicron variante einfach nur die
perverse anreize struktur in chinas
politischer hierarchie
[Musik]
er demonstriert nur wie die macht an der
spitze des systems konzentriert ist und
wie die lokalen parteifunktionäre und
regierungsbeamten nur noch ihrer
karriere bedacht sind und wie diese
karriere nur noch von der loyalität
gegenüber china abhängt nicht von ihrer
kompetenz urteilsfähigkeit geschweige
denn realen erfolgen für die menschen
hinter all dem steckt schießt ambitionen
auf eine dritte amtszeit nach vorbild
maus er weiß dass er nur dann wieder
gewählt werden kann wenn er alle die ihn
wählen unter sich gleich schaltet egal
welche kosten damit im land oder
gesellschaft aufgebürdet werden putin
lässt grüßen die neue 0-coup it kampagne
wird einen hohen wirtschaftlichen tribut
fordern sie unterdrückt den binnenkonsum
weiter sie verschärft die unterbrechung
von lieferketten und fördert die
abwanderung von investoren der zugang
der menschen zu normaler medizinischer
versorgung weiter erschwert und
epidemiologisch gesehen vergrößert die
zwanghafte abschirmung der chinesischen
bevölkerung vor den büros das enorme
immunität defizit gegenüber den rest der
welt was paradoxerweise auf den ausstieg
aus der neue strategische gemacht
anstatt mit dem virus zu leben werden
die chinesen mit einer extrem
kostspieligen machtpolitik leben müssen
die das corona virus weiter
instrumentalisiert die partei und sie
selbst haben von corona und ihrer damit
verbundenen politik extrem profitiert
und sie hat sein image und politisches
schicksal sehr stark mit dem kampf gegen
kuwait 19 verbunden indem er persönlich
befehle erteilt einsätze arrangiert und
den starken mann markiert außerdem wird
eine abkehr von seiner harten politik
der legitimität des regimes schaden da
es nicht mehr behaupten könnte chinas
politisches system sei den westlichen
überlegen der wettbewerb der ideologien
0 corvette auf der einen und leben mit
dem virus auf der anderen seite wird von
den medialen propaganda pekings als
kampf zwischen den politischen systemen
dargestellt
damit könnte das regime sein land jedoch
in eine extrem teure sackgasse hinein
manövriert haben einen abwärts um aus
den ist nicht mehr ohne gesichts und
machtverlust herauskommt der wetteinsatz
der aktuellen politischen führung ist
dermaßen hoch dass sie keine kosten
scheuen wird ihre verfehlte politik
aufrecht zu erhalten während der rest
der welt nun also lernt mit dem virus zu
leben während die chinesin darauf
vorbereitet mindestens zehn jahre lang
mit 0 zu leben ja ich weiß dass and
wahrlich keine schönen aussichten in
china das sich noch weiter von der welt
isoliert vor allem in seinem werten
entfernt und auch hier lässt wieder
putin größen apropos thema doping hat
sich durch seine wette auf russlands
schnellen erfolg in der ukraine schwer
vergaloppiert und putin ist nicht das
erste und auch nicht das letzte falsche
pferd auf das er so viel gesetzt hat
schon im september 2021 musste peking
machtlos mit ansehen wie august eine
strategische militärallianz zwischen den
usa großbritannien und australien
gebildet wurde die darauf abzielt den
chinesischen interessen indopazifischen
regierung entgegenzutreten es war eine
reaktion auf skis aggressives pokerspiel
in der region und weitere werden folgen
ein video über vietnam steht noch an ist
es also war treten wir in eine ära der
die globalisierung ein eine ära in der
sich gruppe machteliten in ihren
positionen fest die sich in egomanisch
größenwahnsinnige abenteuer stürzen und
alle übrigen menschen dass wir die zeche
bezahlen lassen und zwar durch den
massiven verlust von wohlstand
sicherheit und freiheit nun wir werden
diese entwicklung und künftigen videos
genau beobachten und weiter auseinander
nehmen vergessen also bitte nicht das
abo mit glöckchen versehrt keines
unserer videos verpassen möchte ich
danke euch und denkt bitte auch an eine
kleine spende den link dazu habe ich
euch in die beschreibung gepackt fakt
ist dass durch diese politik auch chinas
unternehmen im ausland stark an
glaubwürdigkeit verloren haben und
innerhalb chinas geht ist ihnen auch
nicht viel besser
[Musik]
er war grant einer der führenden
konzerne des landes um 1 das wertvollste
immobilienunternehmen der welt steht
unter konkursverwaltung und ist am rande
des bankrotts seine liquiditätsprobleme
haben das fundament der chinesischen
wirtschaft erschüttert ok aber was hat
das alles mit olympia zu tun wie trägt
dies alles zur beantwortung unserer
fragen vom anfang des videos bei gut
lasst uns also all diese werden nun
zusammenführen aus all den genannten
gründen kam diese olympischen spiele für
shopping zu einem sehr heiklen zeitpunkt
als spiegelbild der lage chinas nach
innen wie nach außen die spiele von 2008
waren immerhin chinas große gala
vorstellung gewesen ein symbol für den
imposanten aufstieg des reiches der
mitte in die oberste liga doch welches
bild hinterließ sie durch olympia 2022
nun obwohl die weitgehend pannenfrei
abliefen werden sie durch ihre krasse
absenz von gefühl menschlichkeit
sportgeist leichtigkeit und offenheit
was olympia doch eigentlich ausmachen
sollten ist das vermächtnis eines
fehlgeschlagenen politischen kalküls in
die geschichte eingehen in den peking
alle inneren und humanistischen werte
welche eine so große
sportveranstaltungen für die menschen
attraktiv und sympathisch macht gezielt
eliminierte degradierte ist die spiele
zu einem für alle welt sichtbaren
symbole für chinas derzeitige
abgestumpftheit moralische dekadenz und
arroganz der macht und natürlich für die
verfall von urteilskraft
führungsqualität und legitimität des
regimes bereits im vorfeld der muskete
pekings unfähigkeit auf die weltweite
besorgnis über die vorwürfe des
teenie-stars peng shuai wegen sexueller
übergriffe gegen einen hochrangigen
teils funktionären einzugehen warum dass
china von heute die hohe messlatte von
peking 2008 nicht mehr erreichen kann
und zwar auch nicht in dem es jedes bild
kontrolliert das nach außen in die welt
bringt tatsächlich unterstrich nur die
abschreckende zensur bei der keine
einzige abweichende stimme zugelassen
war das nur das regime kontrolle über
jeden sportler und jeden menschen in
china ausüben darf davon besessen ist
jedes wort zu diktieren und jeden
schritt zu kontrollieren hinzu kam das
ohrenbetäubende schweigen der anderen
athleten das sport wurde vom gestank der
politik vollkommen überwältigt ihm wurde
die luft zum atmen genommen die
kontrollsucht schwangen sich zu ganz
neuen höhen auf und konnte die
unliebsamen schlagzeilen doch nicht
zurückbringen daher werden die
olympischen spiele in peking als chinas
gescheiterte versuch in die geschichte
eingehen die sport für politische
propaganda zu missbrauchen sie haben der
welt gezeigt dass chinas führung die
wahllose verliert und ihr blatt bei so
gut wie jedem match maßlos über reist
das regime hat den sport zu einem
nebenschauplatz gemacht um der welt ihre
politische agenda auf brutalstmögliche
weise zu verkaufen und diese überaus
plumpe verkaufsstrategie ist gewaltig
nach hinten los gegangen von der
neuesten gewissheit und cleverness
frühere generation chinesischer
politiker ist nichts mehr übrig
geblieben als ein scherbenhaufen aber
jetzt seid ihr erst mal an der reihe was
haltet ihr von olympia 2022 und vom
diplomatischen boykott der spiele durch
den westen was haltet ihr von der devise
wandel durch handel wird sie im falle
chinas genauso scheitern die mit
russland wie immer sind auf eure
beiträge diskussion zu diesem thema
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe also dass
euch das video gefallen hat und was
gelernt habt was ja gibt es mit einem
leicht einen freund und vergesst nicht
dass aber mit glücklich und keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich von uns jederzeit über eine
spende von euch mittels hält dieses
projekt weiterzuführen in paper link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung oder
dem video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]